cette cité a été fondée pour être un
phare dans la nuit nous sommes dans la
cité du progrès notre avenir est radieux
nous étions nous seul et même tribu à
présent
nous sommes que des clans divisée
à mesure que le temps passe et la
surface nos distances de plus en plus
rapidement d'un monde où il n'y avait
jamais assez pour survivre
il peut te briser ou alors te forger en
quelque chose de bien plus grave
salut
je dois parler à un des prisonniers
vous êtes cuivre
quand même essayer il faut que je la
retrouve
house
va
il y a des jambes à dont l'unique
objectif et nous détruire
la seule façon de vaincre un ennemi plus
fort que soi c'est de n'avoir aucune
limite
devrait préparer notre propre espace
vous pensez avoir les toffes aéro
j'ai bien peur que ce ne soit qu'une
trop courte réunion
vous parlez beaucoup 3
[Musique]
nous y voilà
ceux d'en bas vous êtes vraiment tous
les mêmes un petit conseil ne menacez
jamais le type qui vous sert à boire